hi in this video i'm going to
explain the concepts behind iron
exchange chromatography
so the ion exchange chromatography
relies on the principle that our protein
should have some amount of charge in it
and based on the
charge of the protein we would separate
so the basis of charge separation the
basis of separation in iron exchange
chromatography is a charge on the
protein
so here it's given a small example here
is r plus a here r is actually the
matrix
the beads of the matrix which has a
positive charge and a is a negative
charge attached with that matrix now
here b represents our particular protein
that we want to separate from other
proteins
and
what happens this particular protein b
it exchange with a and after that it
gets bind with the matrix and it
replaces a
and this is how it's binds with the
matrix
and after some time
if we uh
want to elute our particular protein b
we would uh apply some
another molecule which have a negative
charge in it
so as ion exchange chromatography is
also a type of column chromatography we
would try to understand
how it would look like inside a column
so we have
specialized beads
one of uh popular beads is ta cellulose
used for anion exchange chromatography
so analysis chromatography means if our
protein is anionic that means in our
protein we have a lot of negatively
charged groups that means a lot of
acidic groups
so
in this column
there are dae cellulose beads if we zoom
into the dac and those beads we can see
d a cellulose beads are actually
positively charged
so if we just try to similar we try to
find the similarity with this equation
so these particular bead represents this
r plus
so in our first step of equilibration we
would be using equilibration buffer
and say for instance this equilibration
buffer turns to be
nacl so in nacl we have a lot of cl
minus
so these cl minus will actually bind to
these positive charge and this cl minus
actually represents these a minus over
here in this equation
and
so in this step we just applied our
equilibration buffer and the cl minus is
actually represented in light blue color
and in the second step where we would
apply sample and our sample may have
some proteins which are positively
charged which are negative which have
some amount of negative charge which
have a greater amount of negative charge
and
what happens
the proteins that have negative charge
will replace this
chlorine ion here and it would bind to
the matrix as shown here so these uh
green like proteins represented here
will bind to these
matrix
and these violet ones they have greater
amount of negative charge that means
greater amount of negative group acidic
group in them they would also bind to
the
beads
but these red ones which have positive
charge they could not bind to these
matrix and this binding happens by
electrostatic interactions
and after sample application what would
happen we have to wash it with the
washing buffer for illusion of our
protein so first what happened these red
proteins it won't
bound with the matrix so it would come
out first after that we have two kind of
proteins we have one protein where we
have a lesser amount of negative charge
and a protein which have which have
greater amount of negative charge
because it has greater amount of acidic
groups so in order to
elude this we should use a
gradient of nacl
so even in a lower nacl concentration
what happens these
proteins which have
low negative charge would be eluted
and how this illusion actually occurs
when we increase the concentration of
the chlorine ion in this step in this
last step what happens if we increase
the chlorine ion
the particular proteins that are bound
here would be replaced by chlorine and
the protein would come out uh from that
particular column but the
proteins which have more amount of
negative charge
their binding would be more strong that
is why we have to use even higher
concentration of
sodium chloride so
if we look at a graph here
so for these red color protein we really
don't need
other ways of illusion but for these
particular green colored protein that
have a unique positive unit negative
charge we can use a sodium chloride and
we you can see that for eluting this
purple color protein
even require more a concentration of
sodium chloride because
these has more negative charge this can
bind with these beads
in a more a
strong manner than the
protein which have a single positive
charge
and for illusion of these proteins
we need even more
concentration of sodium
so
here comes uh two terms one is cation
exchange chromatography another is anion
exchange chromatography so cation
exchange chromography uh means that our
protein is cation and that means our
protein has more amount of basic groups
like lysine arginine etc and to
purify that particular protein or
separate that particular protein we
would be using a
cation exchange column and the cation
exchange column popularly used is
carboxymethyl cellulose and
carboxymethyl cellulose has a carboxy
group so it's our thing is actually
negative so for a cation exchange what
would happen this r would be negative
and our cation would be positive and it
would be exchanged by our particular
protein and it would ultimately yield r
negative b plus and a
so this is the basic concept of uh
cation exchange chromatography and for
anion action chromatography
as we have used here the dae cellulose
it's one of the popular
anion exchange column because it is
positively charged it can bind with any
negative uh
counter ions of the equilibrium buffer
and that would be replaced by other
proteins in our solution
and so our protein here for anion
exchange chromography our protein have
to be anionic uh that that is why the
term and now in exchange chromatography
so our protein have to be anionic that
means it has much more acidic groups
compared to other type of groups so this
is the basic concept of an exchange
chromatography so the as per summary we
can say the basic principle behind the
ion exchange chromatography is protein
are separated on the basis of their
charge the greater the positive or
negative charge
the
the uh
stronger is the binding and hence we
need to use a strong gradient of nacl to
elute that
hope you enjoyed this video please like
and subscribe